Christianity and Islam are the largest
religions in history and together
Christians and Muslims make up about
half the world's population but the
average Christian knows almost nothing
about Islam and the average Muslim knows
almost nothing about Christianity the
difference here is that the average
Christian knows that he knows almost
nothing about Islam whereas the average
Muslim thinks that he knows all about
Christianity when he most certainly does
not I think we're at a point in history
when it's very important for people to
know about both faiths but for very
different reasons this video is for
Muslims who would like to learn
something about what Christians believe
but who might not have a lot of spare
time to study Christianity and for
Christians who would like to share some
Bible verses with their Muslim friends
but who might not be sure what to share
so we'll keep this as simple as possible
we're going to look at four Bible verses
one from each of the four gospels all
four verses are the words of Jesus I
will quote a bit more for context but
we'll focus on just four verses let's
start with the gospel of Luke in Luke
chapter 9: 22 Jesus says to his
disciples the son of man must suffer
many things and be rejected by the
elders and chief priests and scribes and
be killed and and on the third day be
raised who is this son of man just so
everyone understands the context Jesus
is referring to the mysterious son of
man prophesied in the book of The
Prophet Daniel 7: 13 to 14 where Daniel
says in my vision at night I looked and
there before me was one like a son of
man coming with the Clouds Of Heaven he
approached the Ancient of Days and was
led into his presence he was given
Authority glory and Sovereign power All
Nations and peoples of every language
worshiped him his Dominion is an
everlasting Dominion that will not pass
away and his kingdom is one that will
never be
destroyed Jesus claimed to be this son
of man coming with the Clouds Of Heaven
who would be given Authority glory and
Sovereign power who would be worshiped
by All Nations and peoples and who would
have an everlasting dominion and a
kingdom that would never be
destroyed but Jesus said that contrary
to the popular belief of his time the
son of man would suffer many things and
be rejected by the elders and chief
priests and scribes and be killed and on
the third day be
raised Jesus says he's going to be
killed and on the third day be raised
why is he going to be killed he tells us
in in the gospel of Mark in Mark
10:45 Jesus declares for even the son of
man came not to be served but to serve
and to give his life as a ransom for
many again this is Jesus talking this
isn't the Apostle Paul or later
Christians Jesus says that he came to
give his life as a ransom for others
he's going to die for others what should
our response be
Jesus tells us about the will of God in
the Gospel of John in John 6:40 Jesus
says for this is the will of my father
that everyone who looks on the son and
believes in Him should have eternal life
and I will raise him up on the last day
everyone who looks on the son and
believes in Him should have eternal life
and Jesus will raise him up on the last
day do you believe in the
son if so Jesus says that he will raise
you up on the last day Jesus is the one
who raises the dead at the resurrection
that's an interesting claim for Jesus to
make since according to both the Old
Testament and the Quran God is the one
who raises the
Dead who does that make
Jesus now why am I sharing these verses
with you I'm doing it because of what
Jesus says in the gospel of Matthew in
Matthew 28: 19 after Jesus has risen
from the dead he commands his followers
go therefore and Make Disciples of all
Nations baptizing them in the name of
the father and of the son and of the
Holy Spirit baptizing them in the name
singular of the father and of the son
and of the Holy Spirit father Father Son
and Holy Spirit are somehow one but we
have a therefore here and as the saying
goes when you see a therefore you should
see what it's there for so let's read
the
context now the 11 disciples went to
Galilee to the mountain to which Jesus
had directed them and when they saw him
they worshiped him but some doubted and
Jesus came and said to them all
authority in heaven and on Earth Earth
has been given to me go therefore and
Make Disciples of all Nations baptizing
them in the name of the father and of
the son and of the Holy Spirit teaching
them to observe all that I have
commanded you and behold I Am With You
Always to the End of the Age his
disciples who were devout Muslims
according to the Quran worshiped him and
Jesus said all authority in heaven and
on Earth has been given to me what were
the disciples supposed to do they were
supposed to tell the entire world that
Jesus has all authority and that people
of all Nations should therefore be
baptized in the name of the father and
of the son and of the Holy Spirit
doesn't this sound exactly like the
Fulfillment of the prophecy we read in
Daniel 7 in my vision at night I looked
and there before me was one like a son
of man coming with the Clouds Of Heaven
he approached the Ancient of Days and
was led into his presence he was given
Authority glory and Sovereign power All
Nations and peoples of every language
worshiped him his Dominion is an
everlasting Dominion that will not pass
away and his kingdom is one that will
never be
destroyed you see how these Bible
passages are all connected to each other
to convey One Core
message so according to Jesus God is a
trinity Father Son and Holy Spirit the
son entered creation to die as a ransom
after he completed that mission he rose
from the dead and by believing in him we
have eternal life obviously the message
of Jesus completely contradicts The
Message of Islam which is a huge problem
for Islam because Islam affirms the
message of Jesus if you're a Muslim you
may think you can escape this problem by
saying that the gospel has been
corrupted unfortunately for Islam that
Escape Route has been blocked by the
Quran itself the Quran affirms not only
the message of Jesus but also the
inspiration preservation and authority
of the Christian scriptures that
Christians still have which record the
message of Jesus if you'd like proof be
sure to check out my videos 99.8% of
muslims don't know Allah says this about
the Bible and what the Quran really says
about the gospel you won't be
disappointed well you will be
disappointed because you'll realize that
your shakes and imams have been lying to
you for your entire life but once you've
discovered that and discovered the truth
about Jesus remember to get baptized in
the name of the father and of the son
and of the Holy Spirit
[Music]